Traduttore: Roberto Minelli
Revisore: Michele Gianella
È fantastico vedersi
definiti "changemakers".
È una parola che per decenni
abbiamo usato con reverenza,
con timore reverenziale,
e invece mi piace contribuire
a scardinare quest’idea.
In realtà, non è necessario
essere premi Nobel,
non è necessario essere geni o eroi.
Ciascuno, nel suo piccolo, o grande,
può essere attivatore -
attore - di cambiamento.
Ci sono tantissimi esempi:
penso ai bambini di strada di Haiti
che hanno innovato il sistema
della sicurezza stradale;
a una singola ricercatrice tedesca
che è riuscita a mettere in connessione
gli scienziati rifugiati
con quelli locali;
a una ragazzina nordamericana
che ha scritto centinaia di lettere
ed è riuscita a costringere
il provveditorato
a cambiare i manuali scolastici
che avevano immagini
stereotipate delle donne.
Quindi, ora, il ponte
che vorrei contribuire
a costruire stamane,
il cambiamento che voglio affrontare,
riguarda il terzo settore,
il cosiddetto non profit.
E, in particolare,
il modo in cui guardiamo
alle organizzazioni del terzo settore,
il modo in cui ci rapportiamo ad esse.
Quando diciamo terzo settore
ci riferiamo a una galassia
di associazioni,
organizzazioni non governative,
organizzazioni di volontariato,
imprese sociali, cooperative,
fondazioni ed enti filantropici.
340.000 enti, 820.000 dipendenti,
sei milioni e mezzo
di volontari nel nostro paese,
un settore che è cresciuto
del 60 percento negli ultimi 15 anni
e oggi conta l’8 percento
del comparto produttivo italiano.
Ma perché ci interessa il terzo settore?
Non sono solo i numeri.
Il terzo settore ci interessa
perché si occupa delle cause
che ci stanno a cuore;
perché si occupa
dell'umanità, del pianeta,
delle persone più fragili che amiamo.
Il terzo settore ci interessa
perché fa la differenza
per un mondo migliore,
perché ha la capacità
di immaginare l'impossibile
e di riunire centinaia, migliaia,
milioni di persone per una causa.
Vedere le persone con disabilità mentale
come persone, innanzi e prima di tutto;
guardare ai bambini con disabilità
come bambini, soprattutto;
prendersi cura delle persone anziane
come “persone risorsa”
o di una bambina malata come una bambina,
e non soltanto come una paziente;
offrire un approdo sicuro
alle donne vittime di violenza domestica;
combattere il razzismo;
promuovere l'interculturalità
tra nuovi cittadini;
e far capire alla gente
che viviamo in un mondo interconnesso
in cui, per esempio, l'estinzione
delle tartarughe marine a Policoro
è un danno enorme
per la biodiversità di tutto il pianeta.
Ok, la crisi climatica di questi giorni
oggi riguarda qualcuno e non altri;
ma, in realtà, ci riguarda tutti.
Le organizzazioni del terzo settore
non si limitano a tappare
i buchi, o le voragini,
di un sistema di welfare italiano
obsoleto e inefficiente;
le organizzazioni del terzo settore
non si limitano ad attività di supplenza;
le organizzazioni
del terzo settore possono -
di questi chiari di luna, direi devono -
fare la differenza:
cambiare il mondo, trasformare la società,
innescare processi
che riescano a dare valore
non soltanto per il risultato
finale che producono,
ma durante tutto il percorso,
magari lungo e accidentato,
che mettono in atto.
Ora, questa mattina vorrei
contribuire a sfatare due miti,
due falsi miti che - due muri ideologici,
due falsi miti che hanno, in realtà,
impedito al terzo settore del nostro paese
di cambiare il mondo,
tenendolo sotto schiaffo
e lasciandolo in una situazione
di sudditanza e di dipendenza.
Due falsi miti:
la riduzione all'osso
dei costi di struttura
e il lavorare solo per cicli di progetto.
Sul primo:
il mantra imperante è
“Le organizzazioni del terzo settore
devono costare poco.
Tutti i finanziamenti
vanno destinati ai progetti”.
Quindi niente fondi,
niente soldi per la comunicazione,
il fundraising, il management,
lo sviluppo tecnologico e digitale,
lo sviluppo gestionale.
È un percorso, un processo di isomorfismo
che crea un ciclo della fame.
I donatori non vogliono
finanziare costi di struttura,
le organizzazioni
del terzo settore si adeguano
e riducono i costi di struttura,
i donatori finanziano
sempre meno costi di struttura.
Questo dogma, nel nostro
paese, è incontrastato
in tutte le procedure e le prassi
dei donatori pubblici e privati
ma anche nell'opinione pubblica.
Anche noi, quando diamo
il nostro 5 per mille,
quando doniamo per una causa,
quando sottoscriviamo
una petizione o una campagna,
quando partecipiamo a un crowdfunding
vogliamo finanziare progetti,
e non organizzazioni.
Quindi, questa ideologia
ha creato dei progettifici
nelle organizzazioni del terzo settore,
con organizzazioni, strutture, staff
troppo spesso inadeguati.
Tanti giovani del nostro paese -
forse le menti e i cuori migliori -
vogliono cambiare il mondo,
vogliono essere protagonisti
di questo cambiamento;
si avvicinano al terzo settore
e poi scoprono, si rendono conto
che non solo tutta la vita, ogni anno,
guadagnerebbero il 35-40 percento
in meno degli altri settori profit,
ma anche che lavorerebbero
in organizzazioni sottosviluppate,
sottocapacitate,
a cui si richiede di fare
sempre di più, con meno.
E, allora, la domanda per me è:
“Perché, in qualunque settore,
le imprese - diciamo, in generale,
le organizzazioni
che investono nelle persone,
che investono nelle capacità,
che investono nello sviluppo finanziario,
nella comunicazione -
sono quelle che hanno
più probabilità di successo?”.
E, invece, nel terzo settore
questo cambia;
e anche l'imprenditore,
che nella sua attività di impresa
conosce benissimo
il valore dell'investimento
sull'organizzazione,
nella sua attività filantropica
vuole finanziare solo progetti.
In Italia,
le radici profonde di questa ideologia
affondano in vari terreni:
la cultura del volontariato cattolico,
l'inconscio di un paese
in cui, per centinaia di anni,
i servizi sociali sono stati svolti
gratuitamente dalla Chiesa
e, in particolare, da donne -
religiose e laiche - non pagate.
Una serie di dichiarazioni di facciata
nella lotta alla cultura della furberia:
quindi, evitare che i furbi,
o gli pseudo-furbi,
possano riuscire a finanziare
gli amici degli amici;
in generale, la mancanza
di fiducia sociale del nostro paese
e, da parte dei donatori,
la mancanza di -
la paura di assumersi
responsabilità di scelta.
Le organizzazioni del terzo settore
hanno un bisogno vitale
di supporto economico,
di finanziamenti flessibili,
di finanziamenti sulle organizzazioni,
di finanziamenti sulle missioni
perché le organizzazioni possano essere
forti, capaci, innovative e creative.
Finanziamenti per missioni
e non solo su progetti.
E quindi, andiamo al secondo punto.
I progetti possono essere bellissimi,
ma rimangono chiusi in loro stessi,
chiusi in una gassa centripeta
attorcigliata su sé stessa
che è incapace di trasformare la società,
che è incapace di costruire
una trasformazione sistemica
e di provocare un cambiamento sociale.
Lavorare per progetti vuol dire
lavorare per obiettivi specifici,
reinventare una squadra
con dei consulenti, con dei collaboratori,
con del personale di progetto ogni volta;
vuol dire lavorare su tempi
e orizzonti di tempo estremamente brevi -
sei mesi, un anno, due anni -
tempi che sono ridicoli
per riuscire ad avere
un investimento vero
sul cambiamento sociale.
Se io penso ad Amazon,
che nei primi sei anni è stata in perdita,
e ha avuto un capitale paziente -
quel capitale paziente, e flessibile,
che nel terzo settore non c'è.
Per affrontare i grandi temi -
la diseguaglianza crescente, il razzismo,
il cambiamento climatico,
l'impoverimento culturale,
i grandi temi di oggi,
tutti intersezionali -
bisogna investire su missioni,
su missioni interdisciplinari,
e dare flessibilità alle organizzazioni
di investire sulla comunicazione,
di investire sul fundraising,
di investire sul digitale,
sull'organizzazione stessa.
Le organizzazioni e le persone ci sono,
bisogna veramente cambiare le modalità.
Da parte dei donatori,
le modalità di erogare,
di finanziare, di sostenere -
superare la logica
dell'erogatore che dà al beneficiario,
e il beneficiario che riceve.
E costruire, invece,
una partnership di lungo periodo.
Finanziare non per sei mesi,
un anno, due anni;
ma veramente per
cinque - sette anni, almeno,
e riuscire a finanziare su missioni.
Da parte delle organizzazioni
del terzo settore,
è necessario smettere di adattarsi
e quindi riuscire veramente a dire
quali sono gli investimenti
necessari e i costi;
evitare l'isomorfismo
che le ha costrette a fare:
“Esisto perché produco progetti,
e produco progetti per esistere”,
all'inseguimento delle modalità dei bandi.
Esistono già, ci sono
tante iniziative pilota –
pochissime, purtroppo,
nel nostro paese, per il momento -
di nuove modalità di finanziamento,
diverse dai bandi,
che sono invece ancora la modalità
assolutamente dominante nel nostro paese.
Da parte mia,
penso che oggi abbiamo, veramente,
l'opportunità per costruire
un nuovo ponte
tra donatori, investitori, finanziatori,
organizzazioni del terzo settore -
che in realtà, però,
è un ponte che ci riguarda tutti.
E in cui ciascuno di noi,
e tutti insieme,
possiamo veramente fare la differenza.
Giovani che si avvicinano
per la prima volta al terzo settore;
meno giovani che, invece,
vogliono restituire capacità e competenze:
tutti insieme possiamo fare la differenza
perché si tratta, veramente,
di un cambiamento culturale.
E quindi, il ponte che va costruito
è un cambiamento, innanzitutto,
di pensiero e di cultura.
Grazie.
(Applausi)